c'est impossible que c'est physiquement
impossible
ça ne devrait pas être là il n'y a pas de place
c'est seulement vers finalement vers la fin
du film qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a plusieurs
couloirs qui se succèdent derrière le bureau
on le voit quand Wendy
quand elle est plus tard en bas  là et elle voit
le corps de Colin après qu'il a été tué
vous l'avez derrière dans ce couloir
derrière le bureau
et donc vraiment savoir ce que je peux vous dire
sur les cartes je sais que je ne me suis pas assis
avec du papier quadrillé je n'ai même pas commencé à
essayez de les faire à l'échelle laissez-moi voir que je
ne peux pas dire quelle pièce je commence
et je viens de traverser et j'ai décidé que
j'allais essayer de faire tout ce que je pouvais
sentir que je sentais finalement qu'il
y avait des endroits que je pouvais
combattu comme où les filles ont été tuées,
je n'étais pas absolument sûr à ce moment-là
quand j'ai commencé à faire les cartes où
les filles ont été tuées, mais j'ai senti que
c'était quelque part dans la zone où
elles vivaient numéro de suite mais  ils savaient
que la Suite numéro trois